thierry le luron non tout à fait prêts
destinés thierry à 17 ans et demi il
arrive de bagneux dans les
hauts-de-seine
il a quitté le lycée en terminale et il
est dans la recherche d'une situation il
espère bien ce serait une situation dans
le music-hall et aujourd'hui il va
chanter il va chanter la quête de
l'inaccessible rêve extrait de l'homme
de la manche doit signaler que thierry
un nom extraordinaire d'imitateur on le
verra très prochainement la division
dans dans le rôle limité d'or vous
pouvez nous dire bonjour la façon d'un
d'amour très rapidement eh bien je suis
très heureux de me trouver en compagnie
de l'inimitable mars aujourd'hui bien
très bien
je vous assure bien sûr qu'il en connaît
des dizaines comme ça alors maintenant
ils chantent
rêver un impossible horaire
notez le chagrin des débats
le cimetière
aimer jusqu'à la déchirure aimé même
chrono mais ma tante et son ami
tatin
m
suivant les toits
je me sens un peu importe le temps
mathé espérons
et puis tu es toujours sans questions on
y repense d'année pourtant pour l'amour
je ne sais et lévis que la boue ce raid
bleu
qu'un malheureux
comme élan aux biens ayant volé
encore
au même moment pour la toile
l inaction
et toi